well first of all you know every younger
generation faces challenges and and and
one of the advantages of learning
history as it gets you over the
temptation to be a historical and think
you know when i enter journalism a
salary level is considered an
existential crisis time in journalism
and now it's considered an existential
crisis time in journalism what's going
on now is you have a I mean the big
things going on probably the biggest
thing going on is the advent of the
internet which is as a delivery system
for journalism the most important thing
to come along since television and that
has you know it's a challenge for us at
the school and it's it's it's a huge
part of the life of what we do and what
our graduates will do after they
graduate partly because of the internet
there's two other things going on which
is one a change in the economic model
for you know reporters who work for
salaries which is evolving in ways that
we can't be sure of but it's evolving
and then the second is an effacement of
borders it used to be that most
journalism was pretty local really and
and and journalism took place within
communities and that's less and less
true it's American journalism is more
national certainly on the web and and
it's also more international
you